bill it's been a year since the last
story Expo that we talked to you and
your career yeah you look great you
enjoying your time here yes okay
absolutely love story Expo good okay
well we just got here ourselves and I've
been reading this book by joyce carol
oates the faith of a writer and so I've
been kind of asking some of the people
that have sat in that chair this
question and then we'll get to some
other stuff because I know you want to
talk about dialogue she says here the
artist is born damned and struggles with
his or her life to achieve an ever
elusive redemption by way of art a sense
of one's incompleteness or inadequacy
fuels that instinct for ceaseless
invention fascinating thoughts
fascinating um born damned I think that
could be it because you know one of the
there's a thing in oh I think it's Annie
Hall where Woody Allen sees the the
perfect couple and goes you know what
you know why are they so perfect
together and it's like because he's
empty-headed and she doesn't know
anything it's like the writer is the
opposite of that we're the people that
know everything which is part of being
damned as we know things we know why
people do things we kind of can get
under the skins of people and see often
see their motivations and sometimes what
they think is when they think they're
manipulating us instead we're looking at
they were at them going do they think
they're getting away with this and so we
often have a this is going to sound like
I'm superior in subway but often people
writers understand motivations to an
extent where we can see people coming
from a mile away we also sometimes end
up being gullible because of that where
we want to be trusting to people but the
thing about being a screenwriter
specifically being damned is that you
whatever demon makes us want to write I
think what we're really looking for is
some sort of praise we're looking for
we're always looking for people to go
that was you did a great job or that was
a good script i love that script and in
the Hollywood world when they really
loved your script they have a meeting
with you where they tell you everything
that's wrong with it or everything they
want you to change
so you're never going to get any praise
as a screenwriter and one of the things
that I always say is that writing has to
be its own reward because if you're
looking for some producer to go that's
it made me cry they the next thing after
they made me cry is but could they be
Cowboys or you know they're going to
come up with some bizarre change can
take place on Mars you know and that's
where you never get it you're never
going to get praised as a screenwriter
what you're going to get is a check and
all the things that are wrong with your
script or need to be changed so that's
part of our thing where I think we're
we're all may be searching for some sort
of approval and you're never going to
get it as a screenwriter boy that but
it's going to bug you all out I'm sorry
well another chapter in her book talks
about failure and she says that in a
sense a lot of writers are attracted to
failure I think that's true attracted to
failure I don't know if that's true i
think i think we certainly have to live
with a lot of failure because one of the
things about any creative endeavor is
it's not like you can go fill out a job
application to be a screenwriter and hey
we're hiring and you get the job instead
what it is as you write screenplay after
screenplay after screenplay after
screenplay after screenplay and each one
of them gets nothing happens with until
finally you write that screenplay where
somebody reads it and goes this is
wonderful here's how we can change it
and here's everything that's wrong with
it and you know then they cut you a
check hopefully and you then destroy
your screenplay boy they have a story
that I want to tell right now but it's
too soon oh okay okay all right well
maybe story Expo 2016 yeah we can talk
about it okay never write an
autobiographical screenplay because
they'll fire you and hire somebody that
knows your life better than you do or
can see you coming from a mile away or
nose knows how to size you I don't know
see but I don't I don't know if writers
are attracted to failure I think that
we're I think that to some extent to be
a writer to want to sit in a room alone
right stuff on a page makes you
automatically somebody that's not I
don't know doesn't work well with others
in a weird way we're we tend to be
loners I guess I don't know if that
makes us losers but it certainly makes
us you know unusual you know we're we're
we're a lot of us are outcasts to some
degree maybe which maybe gets into the
approval thing and maybe gets into the
you know right and and also to maybe not
losers but maybe overly just losers
overly sensitive to most people are just
like they'd be a lot of stuff that's
true that's true we tend to and again I
think that gets to the emotional part
and the thing that a good writer you
know the a bad writer just writes stuff
that doesn't matter to them a good
writer basically we're gonna who is it
red Smith open a vein and bleed we're
going to take our personal stories and
we're going to try to communicate those
through other characters and situations
with the same personal stories and then
we're going to take something we would
not tell our best friend and we're going
to tell it to hundreds of million of
people worldwide you know and some some
deep thing in our past that that we may
not want anyone to know about except
here it's a movie
you